some want to throw him in the Pokey for
his weird attempt at karaoke
while Brit's Hearts ache Trudeau parties
at a wake
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
otherwise known as a poor man's Gavin
Newsom
he's being accused of disrespect for
seeing Bohemian Rhapsody in a London
hotel lobby while visiting for the
Queen's funeral roll it Bridget
[Music]
what was he thinking huh
Chad sorry probably wasn't just be
grateful he was singing Bohemian
Rhapsody and Not Another One Bites the
Dust
[Applause]
we're gonna have to change my answer
and be thankful he didn't do anything
from Aladdin
all right cat um you know what bothers
me about him
everything but also doesn't he seem like
you know this type of person totally
know this person yeah he was there for
the funeral he was getting jealous that
the queen was getting all this attention
for being dead exactly yep
he was like nerves I want some yeah so
he has to do that I mean of all the
things that disgusted me about him this
doesn't even really make the list more
so you know what he did with the vaccine
mandates and freezing the bank accounts
of people associated with it that's
something that's truly disgusting this
is just dude being a yeah you know Sonny
I guess we could say it's good that he
wasn't singing in blackface this time
this time yes but I was I was um
listening I was watching the Irish
dancers dance to another one bites the
dust so I can't really talk that was it
that's right they they were vicious on
Twitter and I was like okay I'm gonna
laugh but I'm not gonna retweet any of
them
and nobody knows
until the show
by the way this is the number one show
about British royalty look I called out
that I was watching the Irish do it but
I'm not gonna say how much Black America
was doing it too so we it was horrible
and I was just like that's just so bad
and this is like if this is the worst
that Trudeau had compared to what she
went through on Twitter that that was a
piece of cake because it was terrible in
a Twitter verse yeah you know uh uh Dr
Drew um is there one likable thing you
can find about this clown I can't the
hair I find it oh his hair's nice yeah
the hair is nice you have great hair
doctor don't put yourself down
I have different kind of hair totally
different it's really well manicured
it's like a beautiful Aryan lawn it's
almost not real
white makes right on your wow on your
head only on your head
I don't know what the catch us now Doc
good time good time too easy yeah
that's dripping out of all of my
orifices but but listen
wow no I have allergies my eyes leaking
my nose please don't do that yeah they
really don't
I'm following a pilot doctor that this
is this a live intervention
is this live period
what is going on but but listen that
dude lives in a bubble where he gets no
feedback he is so adored by his little
political
Enclave I asked some I tap to talk to
some Canadians tonight I asked him I
said what is wrong Trudeau they said
everything yeah which same thing you
said but they said the reason he's able
to do that he gets no feedback from the
environment so he literally feels that
everything he's done even the more
disgusting stuff that anybody with any
sense ability would know is just not
okay he doesn't pick that up Canadians
are too nice to criticize him but we're
not like that you know what this is the
worst example or the best example of
nepotism ever he only got his job
because of his last name his dad was
prime minister right his you know
whatever who cares but
yourself
[Applause]
Hunter has good connections
there's apples and fruit invest in
vegetables if you want to go get them
and throw
um
wow Gutfeld you know what I uh true
Trudeau's a geek and [ __ ] but again
where did the criticism come from I
think that's what we need to focus on
right that's true if you want to sit
around a bunch of his friends and sing a
really off-key song to God Save the
Queen or whatever
Twitter we're we're giving ground so
another idiot on Twitter we're like it
was so disrespectful don't watch it
[ __ ] yeah you know what I'm saying like
get off your computer we need to stop
giving weight to these these Twitter
punks with their Bots and their fake
likes and crap like you don't like what
he did why are you watching them yeah
you know like start like critic block
them and move on I'm gonna go on Twitter
later tonight and say that and I'll find
you yes just watch it and don't retweet
it good grace yeah exactly off of it
exactly fingerprints completely off of
it is very simple hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else